on this subject of starting out live I
have to ask you anytime I get together
with friends of mine who worked in CERN
out live Bill hader's another good
example we always inevitably fall into
doing our Lorne impressions and I will
say they are done with great love Lorne
Michaels they're they're done with a lot
of affection what I love in effect love
and affection but Bill Hader the last
time he was on the show he started doing
a Lorne impression and it's lauren
name-dropping serial killers rub suits
rubs his eyes and I was curious do you
do a Loren impression I don't know if
you do do you do one I do one in the way
that everybody one phrase you use and
then yeah just eye and then
name-dropping people of course not
serial killers but don't put me on the
spot I don't want notice people often
have one phrase that he says that that's
what they go with like Oh mine is I know
I know I know yeah that's one of them
bill will also do right right right
right right right right
mine is he would say to me you're the
greatest Irish American writer we've
ever had
[Laughter]
he was looking at me it was strange when
you say it after poet nothing he'd look
at me and I meant a lot but he go he
said you know by a mile you'd be great
[Applause]
yeah really specific yeah
and I didn't even do the voice just cuz
it meant so much when you hosted was it
weird to have been a writer and yes
remember that being very very strange
and I still have all the strange things
that have happened to me I find that to
be maybe the most miraculous yeah that
having worked there as a writer and
being so nervous and being so worried
that I might not do a good job if you
would ever told me then that you'll be
back in ten years and you'll be hosting
it I think I would have had you
committed I'm saying I really and to
this day that's one of those things that
and a lot of nice things have happened
for me but that I think maybe beats
everything
yeah it really meant a lot to me there's
also this when you're a writer you're
working you know from Monday to when the
show starts non-stop but you don't have
to go on TV so you can look like garbage
you know you can really be emaciated and
sleep-deprived and stuff right so the
idea of working all week and then having
to go out there and talk it was terrible
it was like I was like a busboy and I'm
like I'm a good busboy but then they
made me the maitre d just keep trying to
refill waters yeah